hey guys sorry I've been mi a a little
absent I've been down in LA filming the
year reviewers movie awards but that is
another video for another time right now
we're gonna talk about what you want to
hear which is Super Bowl highlights that
matter namely one we are hopelessly out
good that's right the Avengers they're
assembling and were pumped so the last
trailer was cool it showed us some
really cool stuff this one shows us a
little more shows Iron Man gearing up it
shows Captain America shield eschews the
slight nning bullet hit and throw on the
top of the Empire State Building like
goes are the ghosts Aryans up there or
something it's awesome and you really
feel like the world needs Avengers I
mean cops Homeland Security Coast Guard
now gonna matter there are a few parts
in this trailer where I was like dude
this is awesome this is what I'm talking
about one is when Iron Man's all flying
up towards one of the props one of the
enemies in battleship right there I was
like okay Joss Whedon what I'm talking
about and as if that wasn't enough we
get to see a little more of the
Incredible Hulk namely the end of the
trailer let's see that again
it's just too badass we have to see it
twice it reminds me of that Hulk
ultimate destruction game where he's
just running he's raging he's in the air
he's hitting stuff he punches a jet in
the mouth if that does not earn this
movie or at least the trailer some
points I just don't know what will and
lastly the final bit the Avenger shot of
Avenger shots
Giroud I'm just glad that I know a shot
like that is in this movie I just that
this movie needs a shot like that that
establishes right there they're like
this is the Avengers movie the
culmination of the past few years
building up to this based on this
trailer alone and that one epic shot
right there this looks like it's gonna
be the Avengers movie that you want the
Avengers movie to be but it's a trailer
I mean you don't know for sure but so
far so good and I've heard some
naysayers some people are like oh and
that one shot where it circles around
you know the epic shot the Hulk's not
there and then he appears right there oh
maybe it's incomplete or is it go back
just enough and right there Hulk elbow
it's all good and yes I know there's
another trailer that I need to talk
about that's the next video until then
enjoy this one so The Avengers trailer
have you seen is this the trailer that
brought you over if you were like I
don't know about Avengers did you see
this were you like yeah that shot is
awesome comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more we're not ending on my
punch but rather
[Music]